When I started this project, my father looked at me like I had two heads.
He was like, "What are you doing with all this plastic?"
We're a leather company.
We're a leather factory.
We've been making leather goods for the last 35 years.
Like in here, you have CVS bags.
In here, you have a... these are ShopRite bags.
When I introduced this idea to my employees,...
...they all thought I was a little crazy as well.
With each aNYbag, we use 95 single-use plastic bags...
...or two pounds of plastic to make one bag.
There's no machine out there that was made specifically for what we're doing.
We're rigging all our leather machines to make this work.
Each bag is individual to itself.
Each bag is a different story.
It's as authentic as you can get to New York City.
So this is basically the last step where I just examine it,...
...make sure everything was stitched up properly.
And it's sturdy.
Hammer it to give it the crease.
And there you go.
aNYbag is complete.
With the aNYbag project, my goal is not to just clean up New York City.
It's to clean up all cities and eventually the world,...
...where we start building pop-up shops,...
...little markets where we teach other people how to do this.